hi everyone
this is professor mda science and today
we're going to be talking about lateral
apparatus in angular momentum
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics in the context of
angular momentum and as their name
suggests ladder operators allow us to
change the value of the angular momentum
by some discrete amount
therefore going up and down a ladder of
discrete angular momentum values the
reason why lateral apparatus are so
useful
is that in quantum mechanics angular
momentum is quantized
and so it can only change in discrete
steps now
this video is going to be a little
mathematical because we're going to look
into the details of ladder operators but
it will be really useful because we're
going to use them all the time
in other videos on angular momentum and
on top of that
similar concepts are used in other areas
such as the quantum harmonic oscillator
or even in more advanced topics such as
second quantization
so let's go let's start with a quick
reminder of angular momentum in quantum
mechanics
and for the full details you should
check the corresponding video linked in
the description
in quantum mechanics an angular momentum
operator j
is an operator made of three separate
components j1
j2 and j3 the key requirement for these
components
is that they must obey these computation
relations
and you will remember from the video on
angular momentum that epsilon ijk
is the levitivitas symbol and that we're
using einstein notation
so that an expression like this implies
a sum
over repeated indices in this case over
the k
indices so this is a definition
of a general angular momentum in quantum
mechanics this includes
orbital angular momentum which we
typically denote by the letter
l and which plays the same role
as the equivalent quantity in classical
mechanics
however in quantum mechanics we also
have this spin angular momentum
without a classical analog if we want to
specify that we're working with spin
then we typically use the letter s
today we will keep the discussion
general so we'll work in terms of the
general angular momentum j
up here and all results we derive will
be valid for
any type of angular momentum
as the different angular momentum
components don't commute they
don't form a set of compatible
observables so we cannot use j1 j2 and
j3
as the basic building blocks of the
theory
instead we found in the video on angular
momentum
that the operator j squared does commute
with each individual component this
suggests that we can build a set
of commuting observables by combining j
squared and one of the components ji
the conventional choice is to use j3
although in principle we could have
chosen any other component
so moving forward we will describe the
physical observables of angular momentum
through these two operators j1 and j2
are still needed for the development of
the theory
but since they are not part of the set
of compatible observables
then we have some flexibility in how
exactly we work
with j1 and j2 it turns out that in the
theory of angular momentum
it is often more convenient to work with
a specific set
of linear combinations of j1 and j2
rather than using j1 and j2 directly
i therefore introduce you to the lateral
writers
as you probably guessed the lateral
braces are linear combinations of j1 and
j2
and there are two of them the first one
is called the racing operator
we label it with j plus and it is
defined as equal to j1
plus ij2 the second one is called
the lowering operator we label it with j
minus and it is defined as equal to j1
minus i j2
at this stage we're just going to accept
that these operators are called
racing and lowering operators and
collectively called lateral apparatuses
but the rationale for these names will
become clear later in the video
ladder operators play a key role in the
study of angular momentum in quantum
mechanics
so the objective of this video is to
work through some of the properties that
will prove
extremely useful in many other videos
the very first property of lateral
parasites is that they are
not hermitian so they are not
observables
in fact j plus and j minus are each
other's adjoint operators
to see this consider j plus dagger
it equals j 1 plus i j j2 dagger
and we can expand this bracket and then
using the fact that j1 and j2 are
emission
we get this this is the definition of
j minus of course the opposite follows
and j
minus dagger is equal to j plus
the angular momentum of races that we
had been working with
until now where j squared and then
j3 j1 and j2 but as we discovered today
we can actually be flexible in how we
incorporate j1 and j2 into the theory
and very often it will prove more
convenient to work in terms of j
plus and j minus which are linear
combinations of j 1 and j
2. the fact that j plus and j minus
aren't observables is not a problem
because we're anyway restricted to j
squared and j 3 as the set of commuting
observables
therefore from now on we are going to
consider either this set here
or this new set of four operators
which contains the same information
given that this second set with j plus
and j minus
is very useful in many problems in the
rest of this video we're going to
explore the properties of the ladder
operators
the squared angular momentum is
generally given by this expression
in terms of the angular momentum
components
however given that we'll mostly use
these four operators to study angular
momentum in quantum mechanics we should
write j
squared in terms of j plus and j minus
rather than in terms of j1 and j2
to accomplish this consider j plus times
j minus
explicitly writing the definitions of j
plus and j minus gives
this and carrying out the multiplication
we get
these four terms
the first two carry through unchanged
and these last two terms can be grouped
into this
commutator the commutator is equal to ih
bar j3
so that we get j1 squared plus j2
squared
plus h bar j3
we can use the expression of j squared
in terms of the angular momentum
components up here
to rewrite the sum of these two terms as
j squared minus j 3 squared
and we get to the final expression j
squared
minus j 3 squared plus h bar
j 3. repeating the same exercise with
the product
j minus times j plus
we get j squared minus j 3 squared minus
h bar j three
we can now add these two expressions
and this equals two j squared minus
two j three squared and we can finally
rearrange to isolate j squared and we
get that j
squared is equal to one half j plus j
minus plus j minus j plus
plus j three squared
of course you don't need to remember any
of these
but we're going to use them constantly
in our study of angular momentum so you
should either be ready to derive them as
needed
or simply keep a list for reference
let's look at the computation relations
j
squared trivially commutes with both j
plus and j minus
to see this let's first write out j plus
and j minus
so we get this and then as j squared
commutes with both j1
and j2 we get 0.
next let's consider the commutator of j3
with jplus
in this case things are not so easy so
let's again start by expanding j
plus and then
we can separate this expression into two
commutators
this is i h bar j two and this is
minus i h bar j 1
so we get h bar multiplying i j
2 plus j 1 and this term is simply j
plus so we get h bar j plus
we can use an analogous derivation to
show that the commutator of j3
with j minus is equal to minus h-bar
j minus the final commutator we can look
at
is that between j plus and j minus
writing out both ladder operators we get
this we can now expand this
into these four terms
and feel free to pause here for a second
to double check this
but it should be clear after a moment
these two terms are 0 because they
involve the same angular momentum
component
this is ihbar j3 and this is
minus i h bar j 3
so that overall we get 2 h bar j 3.
so as a summary of the computation
relations we have that the j
squared operator commutes with all of j3
j plus and j minus
then the j3 operator obeys these
computation relations with the j
plus and j minus operators
and finally the j plus and j minus
operators
obey this computation relation
again you don't need to remember any of
these
but do keep them close because we'll
also use them
all the time
we're now ready to investigate how the
ladder operators act on eigenstates of
the angular momentum observable so this
is the exciting part
as we've been discussing we're
considering j squared and j3
as the two compatible observables to
describe angular momentum
so we'll start by writing down their
eigenvalue equations
the eigenvalue equation for j squared is
this
where the eigenvalue is lambda
and for j3 is this where the eigenvalue
is mu
as j squared and j3 are compatible
observables we can always find a common
set of eigenstates
and we'll take these states labeled by
the eigenvalues
lambda and mu to be this common set
now before we proceed let's discuss
these equations in a little bit more
detail
as we discuss in the video on angular
momentum eigenvalues
it turns out that lambda and mu can only
take
very special values in particular
lambda is always given by j times j
plus 1 times h-bar squared where j is
equal
to one of zero one half one three halves
and so on
in steps of one half
mu on the other hand is always given by
the expression
m times h bar and for a given j
m can only take the values minus j
minus j plus one and so on in steps of
one
up to a maximum value of j
despite this the properties we want to
derive today
don't depend on these special values
that lambda and mu take
so we're going to keep the discussion
general and use lambda and mu
directly for completeness at the end of
the video we will quote
all the results we obtain using the
special values that lambda and mu can
actually take
let's start by constructing a new state
j plus minus
acting on the eigenstate lambda mu
the first result we consider is that if
lambda mu is an eigenstate of j
squared with eigenvalue lambda then this
new state is
also an eigenstate of j squared with the
same eigenvalue
to see this let's act with j squared on
this state
and as j squared commutes with both j
plus and j
minus we can exchange the order here and
we get this
now we can use the eigenvalue equation
for j squared
to get lambda lambda mu and this leads
to lambda times
j plus minus lambda mu
so we see that by acting with j squared
on this state
we get lambda times the same state
and this confirms that j plus minus
lambda mu is also an eigenstate of j
squared
with eigenvalue lambda
let's now make some room and consider j3
the result for j3 is that if lambda mu
is an eigenstate of j3 with eigenvalue
mu
then these new states are also
eigenstates of j3
but this time with different eigenvalues
that we are about to calculate
to do this let's start with j3 acting on
the state
generated from j plus and
looking at the computator up here we can
copy it
and we can rearrange it to j 3
j plus is equal to j plus j 3 plus
h bar j plus using this expression we
get this
and here we can use the eigenvalue
equation for j3 to get
mu lambda mu so that overall we get
mu plus h bar multiplying j plus
lambda mu so what does this mean
we see that by acting with j 3 on this
state
we get a scalar mu plus h bar
times the same state this confirms that
j
plus lambda mu is also an eigen state of
j 3 and the eigenvalue is now
mu plus h bar repeating the same
exercise with j minus we would find that
j
3 acting on j minus lambda mu equals mu
minus h bar multiplying j minus lambda
mu
so in conclusion j minus lambda mu is
also an eigen state of j
3 and this time the eigenvalue is mu
minus h bar
so these up here are the two equations
we have just derived
if we start with j plus the first
equation tells us that j
plus lambda mu is an eigenstate of j
squared with eigenvalue
lambda the second equation tells us that
it is also
an eigenstate of j3 with eigenvalue
mu plus h bar this means that we can
rewrite
this state as lambda mu plus h bar
and in general we will have some
normalization constant in front which
we're going to call
n plus so what does j
plus do when acting on an eigenstate of
j
squared and j3 it simply gives us
another eigenstate of these two
operators
but the j3 eigenvalue has been raised
by a constant h-bar and this
is the reason why we call j plus a
raising operator
we can do the same by looking at j minus
acting on lambda mu
which is an eigen state of j squared
with eigenvalue lambda
and an eigen state of j 3 with
eigenvalue
mu minus h bar this means that we can
write the action of j
minus on an eigen state of angular
momentum like this
and as the eigenvalue of j3 is lowered
by a constant h bar
we call j minus a lowering operator
acting with the racing operator multiple
times
allows us to go up a ladder of
eigenvalues every time adding an
extra h-bar while acting with the
lowering operator we go
down a ladder removing one h-bar each
step
hence the collective name ladder
operators
let's look in more detail at the new
state generated by applying
the lateral operators if we start with
the raising operator
then let's consider the norm of j plus
lambda mu
by definition this is equal to this
and the add joint of j plus is simply j
minus so we can rewrite it like this
and using this expression above we can
rewrite j minus j plus
in terms of j squared and j 3 and we get
these three terms
and feel free to pause here for a second
to double check this
but it should be clear after a moment
using the eigenvalue equations we get
lambda lambda mu
mu squared lambda mu and mu lambda mu
so that we get these new three terms
the eigenstates form an orthonormal set
so we end up with lambda minus mu
squared
minus mu h bar
at the same time we can write j plus
lambda mu
as equal to n plus lambda mu plus h bar
and its norm
is then simply equal to absolute value
of n plus squared
this expression and this expression are
equal
because they're both the norm of j plus
lambda mu
this means that j plus acting on this
state
gives this square root
multiplying the state in which the
eigenvalue mu
has increased by h bar
we can of course repeat the same
exercise with j minus and this is
the corresponding result
again no need to remember any of this
but it will come in handy in our study
of angular momentum
in quantum mechanics
the very last thing i want to do before
we conclude
is to rewrite this final result in terms
of the allowed values of
lambda and mu for angular momentum
eigenvalues
so that you can use this final answer
for reference
let's write down the eigenvalue
equations for j squared
and j3 and as we discussed earlier in
the
videos on eigenvalues of the angular
momentum operators
we learned that the eigenvalue lambda is
always given by
j times j plus 1 h bar squared where j
can only be zero one half one three
halves and so on in steps of one half
and so once we have determined j then
the values of mu
are also fixed and can be written as m
h bar wherein can only take one of the
values
minus j minus j plus one all the way to
j
in steps of one knowing that the
eigenvalues
always have this form then we could
update the eigenstates from
lambda mu to these new labels
however to simplify notation this is
typically simply written
as jm in terms of these
the action of the raising operator on an
eigenstate jm
is simply equal to this normalization
times a new eigenstate j n plus 1.
writing down the corresponding
expression for the lowering operator
we get this
hooray we're done here
i simply have a list of the main results
that we have obtained today
we'll use them in many of the other
videos on angular momentum in quantum
mechanics so an easy way to keep them
handy
might be for you to copy them down or
simply to take a screenshot
ladder operators are extremely useful
when working with angular momentum in
quantum mechanics
so although this video might have
appeared a little too dry the first time
you watch it
we're going to use these results all the
time so it was time well invested
check out the what next section in the
description to see lateral apparatus in
action more generally lateral operators
play a really important role in other
parts of quantum mechanics
most popularly in the quantum harmonic
oscillator and if you want to explore
more advanced topics that build on
similar ideas
i encourage you to watch the playlist on
second quantization
and as always if you liked the video
please subscribe